dan and I realm welcome to none of the
above I'm your host on trolley and today
I'm joined by david pakman of the david
pakman show data thanks for agreeing to
talk to me today my pleasure ok um so
hopefully we're going to discuss money
in politics now there are some
libertarians who will say I should be
able to give as much money as i like to
whoever I want what's the issue what's
wrong with that what would you say to
them well when we're talking about
libertarian sort of implicit in that is
this concept of Liberty and whenever you
talk about liberty or freedom you have
to talk about not only the freedom to do
something but freedom from something and
when we talk about for example here in
the United States religious freedom very
often those advocating for what they see
as their own religious freedom are sort
of implying in the solutions that they
suggest that others might have lack of
freedom from religion I think a similar
analogy exists when we talk about
politics and donations and the idea that
if what we believe is that every person
gets one vote and that that vote that
individual should have sort of equal
impact on the results of an election
you're drastically skewing that freedom
to be a full participant in democracy to
the extent that you believe we have one
rather than you know Ella Garth you're a
kleptocracy or some of the other terms
that are now being used in the u.s.
unlimited campaign donations might
represent the freedom of those who have
the money to make those donations and
when we talk about really large
donations it's a very small percentage
of the American population anyway but
it's restricting the freedom of those
who don't have that money from being
equal in full participants in democracy
and a common counter-argument to this
would be well hey everybody has the same
freedom to make as much money as they
want and then donate as much of it
they want to two politicians the
statistics and studies don't bear that
out right income mobility in the United
States a recent study said it's half of
that in Canada for example the the
ability to move from lower class up so
only if you actually had that mobility
from lower middle class to to somebody
who is Richard with that argument apply
and and one other thing I would say is
the other sort of inherent problem to
the discussion of money in politics is
that we know from a Princeton study that
the legislative desires and ideas and
preferences of big corporations and the
very rich are disproportionately more
likely to be taken seriously by our
elected officials and made into law such
that even in not in this theoretical way
that we're talking about you know
amorphous donations of whatever amount
somebody wants to make in practice if
you don't have large donations to make
or powers through a corporate entity
that you might be involved in what you
want to see done by elected officials in
the United States is far less likely to
happen there's really not much freedom
there and would you accept that that
perhaps is the reason why someone like
Hillary Clinton what for the most part
was unpopular because she was seen as
somebody who was taking a lot of money
from corporations and a lot of large
individual donations I think it's
undeniable that that was a factor
however in one of the sort of calling
cards of Bernie Sanders is campaign in
the Democratic primary was that he's
raising money from primarily small
donations and individual donors and it
wasn't enough to help him defeat Hillary
Clinton in the primary now of course
we've covered extensively how the
Democratic National Committee sort of
had their hand on the scale in favor of
Hillary Clinton and the effect that that
had we can't measure it exactly but
there's there's no real way to deny that
it had an effect so we could have that
conversation but
don't think that alone was the reason
that Hillary Clinton didn't ultimately
defeat Donald Trump and that that's sort
of a large other conversation there's a
you're sort of getting a systemic
problem that exists also which is the
people who are in power are in power
because of the system that currently
exists with regard to money in politics
so their incentive to change that system
is going to be limited so what's the
best and most effective way gladly to
limit the influence is having yeah I
mean citizens united has been a disaster
and that's something that should be
looked at and we should look at
overturning that we should also look at
ranked choice voting or Instant Runoff
voting which will it doesn't directly
impact the system of what's legal in
terms of donations but it does create a
better framework where voters might be
more willing to vote for a third-party
candidate without the fear that they
would end up helping the candidate
that's further from their political
ideology and the state of Maine past
this after the november eighth election
here and I think ranked choice voting if
we are going to try to start to to take
down the two-party duopoly that exists
I'm convinced that wrench choice or
Instant Runoff voting is going to be a
big part of that what about a cap on the
amount that individual people can donate
to politicians sure and there are some
caps and again this is one of those
areas where if you really have a lot of
money there are mechanisms that exist
that allow you to donate much more than
what the on paper cap is for one cycle
or to one candidate but you know
ostensibly some of these caps do exist
but I agree with you that you know
fundamentally what's at odds with those
limits is this concept that money is
speech and this relates to citizens
united and of course Supreme Court
situation we're talking about free
speech a First Amendment which are often
touchy and misunderstood aspects in the
United States very often but certainly
that's something that you can do but
again if someone is fundamental
convinced that freedom is represented by
being able to donate whatever they want
to whomever they want at any time that's
going to be a wall your group you're
going to come up against the barrier you
will come up against when trying to
limit what someone is able to do with
their own money do you think that the
current u.s. campaign finance system
played a role in the popularity of
Donald Trump because he was not taking
as much large individual donations from
others as several other candidates so he
was in a way seen as anti-establishment
oh yeah I think it played a role I think
it was more in the way that Donald Trump
was able to use and craft a narrative
around it the reality is that Donald
Trump was just a much of as much a
participant in the status quo of
campaign finance on the side of making
donations and buying politicians so to
speak but from a PR perspective he
absolutely benefited because as as in
someone who did not hold elected office
before he was not a recipient of those
funds and there's a debate to be had
over what's worse being bought by the
system or buying with the system
different people would have sort of
different perspectives on that but it's
undeniable that he had to he had an
optics benefit from that no question how
do you think he managed to make himself
come across that way I've kind of
anti-establishment in the eyes of some
people having been a must in the system
himself as he say it there are many ways
and how these rank in terms of their
impact or influence it could be debated
I mean this so to give you a sense of
the range the ways in which he was able
to portray himself as anti-establishment
although as we've now seen his cabinet
is effectively an establishment cabinet
his staff is establishments that it
ranged from something as simple as the
language he used and the way he spoke
right that was a really strong aspect he
didn't sound like an establishment
politician that's one thing and on the
other side she crafts
did some pretty strong narrative against
Hillary Clinton which really contrasted
the reality is this is a rich Manhattan
guy who was handed a really great
situation by his father and in many ways
represents the establishment just not
the political establishment in the way
many people were familiar with so they
saw him as different than that even
though in many ways the Trump type is
responsible for the system that we have
he just was a different type of player
within that system if that sort of makes
sense I think also the policies that he
proposed to the extent that they were
policies and not just sort of
off-the-cuff remarks based on what
someone had told him five minutes before
he went on stage would be something
interesting to say the this idea that he
was not going to be politically correct
also played really well because that
translates as he'll do what he quote
really thinks his right versus what's
expected but again as we're quickly
seeing day after day it was it was
really a narrative that appeals to many
people who are not actually going to
benefit from the policies that Donald
Trump is going to enact but that that
may be a different discussion so do you
think the penny is going to drop for
many people when it comes to trump and
if so when and how I don't know I mean
I've been talking a lot about this you
don't Enders if you search my youtube
channel for the word bamboozled which is
a word I've been using with some
frequency I discussed with you know in
some detail the ways in which the
policies that the Trump administration
looks like they're going to at least try
to enact will not help the majority of
Trump voters and this was a really
common of trend with the Tea Party
movement in the United States in 2010
which is that they supported elected
officials who touted ideas that would
never be likely to benefit those
supporters and a lot of it was based
around the idea that a literal belief in
the so-called American dream that you
too may someday be rich enough to
benefit from the policies that are being
proposed and not be hurt by the
elimination of something like the
Affordable Care Act that idea catalyzed
a lot of support for the tea party even
though we know statistically as I've
mentioned earlier in the show with with
income and class mobility as low as it
is in the United States it's very
unlikely that many of those lower middle
class and middle class voters will ever
actually benefit from many of these
policies so the one good thing that
exists and by good i mean not not good
for the country but good in terms of
voters learning that maybe the policies
they voted for won't help them is that
we have a house and a Senate currently
that's controlled by Republicans and of
course we have a Republican in the White
House if things go badly in the next
four years a logical person would think
there is no one to blame but the
Republicans that are there however I
don't want to underestimate the ability
of the committed trumpets to rationalize
what takes place in a way that that does
not blame who's in power one such way
would be well you know what things were
bad these last four years but they
weren't bad because the policy ideas
were bad it was bad because a contingent
of the Republican Party was at odds with
Donald Trump and that created
obstructionism and it would have been
really great if Trump was just allowed
to do what you wanted right that's one
way that it could potentially go another
way it could potentially go as Trump's
ideas really are the right and great
ideas the reason things didn't improve
for me is because of the quote mess that
was left over by President Barack Obama
right that's another way that that lack
of progress or flourishing on your Trump
might be explained away and you know
there's a long list of these that I
could come up with but I think you get
the sort of idea let's talk about the
political left in the US the mainstream
political left how do you think the
mainstream political left in the u.s.
and best convince trunk closes to their
size yeah so there's sort of two ways to
approach this one way is it's not worth
trying to convince them and that simply
by working on voter turnout the American
Left doesn't need to convince anybody we
know that if voter turnout had been
higher it was embarrassingly low on
november eighth hear that Donald Trump
just wouldn't have one right I mean
ultimately he won because of seventy
seven thousand votes across three key
states a very small increase in a
democratic voter turnout would have
prevented Donald Trump from from winning
the election so there's one perspective
which is the American Left shouldn't try
to convince trumpets of anything it
might be possible to convince some of
them but this was a bad idea but it's
way more work to do that than to work on
voter turnout okay so that's one
perspective the other side of this is
and I've talked about this quite a bit
is it's really important right now for
the American Left not to become
fragmented and there was this sort of
reflexive and understandable blame game
that started taking place I think
November 9th might be late it was
probably by about ten p.m. eastern on
november eighth that it started
happening when it became clear that
things we're not going hillary clinton's
way of saying well who's to blame jill
stein is to blame or for example the
Democratic National Committee is to
blame or identity politics is to blame
corporate Democrats are to blame
so-called social justice warriors are to
blame etc I think that that is something
that before we even think about
convincing Trump voters of X Y or Z it
needs to be really clear what the
narrative and platform needs to be of
the Democratic Party and if someone's
like me who isn't a Democrat I've never
been a Democrat or a Republican I'm
unread just in that in the state of
Massachusetts right with your not
independent you're just unregistered I
think it's particularly important to
have a platform if the most progressive
candidate is going to be the Democrat
which that may be the case it's really
important to have a platform that will
apply or appeal to
the broadest portion of the electorate
that that it can I think that the the
path forward has to be a message that is
more about economics and what is corrupt
and what isn't correct what is crony
capitalism and what isn't and you know
just earlier recently on my program a
caller asked me David you know you've
been critical of aspects of identity
politics on your program will you now
denounce social justice warriors and I
said no of course not i mean you know i
think that the term social justice
warrior has become a sort of insult and
i think it's a term that doesn't even
really apply in many cases I think what
needs to be important on the left is we
recognize the ways in which minority
groups have been disproportionately hurt
by much of the crony capitalism and
economic status quo let's come up with a
message that focuses on these
institutions that have way too much
power in the United States that have led
to the concentration of wealth and
income at the very top at the expense or
on the backs of productivity that came
from the average worker and let's craft
the message in such a way that it will
have number one broad appeal but at the
same time have the effect of helping
those most in need and I think that it's
crafted correctly and when I say crafted
I don't mean in a way that's deceptive I
mean just explained in a way that is
accurate it will have the impact of
helping all of those minority groups
that are understandably very concerned
under Donald Trump so this puts me at
odds with a lot of people on the
American left there are those who think
that we should completely ignore any
aspects of discrimination and or sort of
worsening the positions of minority
groups and I don't agree with that at
all and there are those who say that
actually the language that is used
should primarily focus on identity
politics and I also don't agree with
that so so in a centime
I'm not completely on board with either
side of this debate do you think the
mainstream US political left then is too
enamored with identity politics or do
you think it's not embracing it enough
what would you what do you think should
change I don't think that there's a
definitive answer to what the mainstream
American Left thinks or is doing because
it's not clear what the mainstream
American left is at least in this sort
of colloquial sense I mean when you
asked American voters very
straightforward questions you get
sometimes incomprehensible data as a
result so for example if you poll
Americans about individual provisions in
the Affordable Care Act / Obamacare
which is the same thing right and even
that distinction is something that's law
in many Americans they think two
different things done again Obamacare
but the Affordable Care Act is good
crazy right i mean these are the types
of survey responses that we're dealing
with here the provisions in the
Affordable Care Act are very very very
popular but when you then go and ask
people whether they want to see the
Affordable Care Act eliminated you get
way more people than you should based on
the popularity of the provisions that
say yes now lately and this may be a
problem for the Trump administration the
number of people who want the Affordable
Care Act repealed is very very low
that's sort of a sidebar in terms of
what's happening right now so can we say
that the mainstream whatever group of
voters is in favor of this legislation
because they love the provisions or
they're against it because they want it
repealed I don't know the answer to that
and this is why optics and PR and
talking points and the propaganda war
are just so important another example
would be with gun control right if we
talk about and I'm getting away a little
bit from the American left which is sort
of American background checks for any
purchase of a firearm relatively
uncontroversial 85 eighty-eight percent
support for that if we had an actual
accurate representation by our elected
officials of public opinion of that we
would have passed Universal and total
background checks for firearm purchases
a while ago but it's not happening and
that's because of a lot of the PR around
restrictions on guns so these are just
some of the ways in which i think it's
really difficult to say here's what the
quote mainstream american left things
and thus we should do X Y or Z so why is
the PR wool if you like being looked by
people on the left with respect to those
issues a couple of reasons I think
number one and this is something that's
a more fundamental issue the reality of
most issues is nuanced and by its very
nature we have a sort of two elements
that have a sort of bias towards what
end up being right wing positions on
issues number one is there's a sort of
bias towards simplicity if I can
understand or believe I understand an
issue with a very simple explanation I'm
going to have a tendency or one is going
to have a tendency to favor that
explanation so really simple example hey
the government is taking money when you
pay taxes if your money taxes are bad
lower taxes are good tax relief sort of
the phrase tax relief has that built
into it that's a really nice compact and
simple way to get people to say I want
an elected official who's going to
reduce taxes because the counter to that
is not all taxes are great let's raise
taxes as much as we can write the
counter is much more nuanced it's listen
there are really good questions about
what the tax rate should be but more
importantly how those taxes should be
used by the government and if we
compared to European countries who have
not drastically higher tax rates but
different priorities in terms of how
that tax money is used I'm already
getting into the weeds for many people
when i'm already at a disadvantage right
so this growth the sort of bias towards
simplicity that exists come by
this with the corporate media format of
the United States six minute segments
between commercials 20 seconds per guest
to try to articulate their opinion going
back and forth rapid-fire you have a
situation where people are inherently
going to favor simpler explanations or
simpler ideas and a corporate media
environment that mostly only allows for
those simple ideas recipe for disaster
so what should the response of left
wingers be should it be to simplify them
message more or should it be to continue
explaining their positions in that
nuanced way in the hope that what
they're saying will resonate right so
let's talk about the first idea first
simplify the message thomas frank has
written a lot about this and a george
leigh cough has written even more about
this issue and this is how the American
left talks about issues what the right
issues should be etc I don't know
whether just simplifying language on the
left is a totally self self contained
winning strategy it would be great to
have ways to discuss a lot of these
issues in ways that would be you know I
don't I hesitate to use the term simpler
but seemingly more straightforward I
guess would be the case I just don't
know that it's necessarily the way
forward I tend to favor what I sort of
alluded to before was you can try to
change the narrative so instead of
fighting on the minutiae of well listen
if we lower taxes then here's what
happens to the deficit and it
disproportionately benefit the rich and
here's what happens when we did X Y or Z
in this example in the past I think if
you can reframe the narrative around hey
listen whatever your background whatever
your religion etc we have a problem in
this country with crony capitalism we
have a problem in this country with the
work of the average person being
redistributed up
words right the Republicans like to talk
about redistribution of income to the
poor we have redistribution of income to
the very rich through stock ownership
and executive bonuses all on the backs
of the average worker who just goes in
and clocks in and out for 45 hours a
week if you can craft a message around
that with and I'm totally fine with that
message including that there are women
and minorities and immigrants and
whoever else that are disproportionately
negatively affected by it by these
status clothes I believe that that's a
message that may have the most sort of
the broadest resonance and actually help
to fight back against what are really
some pretty I won't call them good but
effective narratives from the right on
political issues so where did Bonnie
Saunders go wrong them because that that
seems by and large will his message was
if you believe that the DNC's hand on
the scale so to speak to help Hillary
Clinton was the reason that Bernie
Sanders ultimately lost you could argue
nothing went wrong in other words that
it was not a fair primary that's one
perspective I absolutely am of the
opinion that the DNC was committed to
helping Hillary Clinton from the get-go
it's hard to measure the absence of
something so I can't say with certitude
that Bernie Sanders would have won the
primary were it not for the DNC sort of
from from the get-go supporting Hillary
Clinton I think that some of the
narratives that were created around
Bernie Sanders were not particularly
useful even though the term socialist in
the u.s. is considered the least bad
that it has been in a very long time the
deliberate confusion between democratic
socialism which is basically regulated
capitalism with a sort of a social
safety net for a number of different
areas of life right it's not actually
socialism it was deliberately sort of
conflated with socialism in a very
different sense i think that that hurt
bernie sanders in a significant
way less significant we been at might
have 20 years ago or ten years ago again
based on the sort of general public
opinion about the term socialism right
now I think that that was very very
damaging and ultimately you had
circumstances where it was stacked
against Bernie Sanders in a significant
way aside from the DNC just sort of
systemically so I think the answer to
the question of if Bernie Sanders had
the economic message why wasn't he
ultimately the nominee it sort of
depends on what you believe took place
during the however many months it wasn't
the primary I think it's a combination
of all of these issues I think again
whether i can say definitively that the
DNC's help of hillary clinton was what
pushed her over the edge versus Bernie
Sanders I don't think I even need to
figure that out I think it was a factor
and that combined with the corporate
media a corporate media in the US did
not acknowledge the existence of Bernie
Sanders until it would have been totally
and publicly embarrassing not to do so
right when his the polling numbers
improved and it was abundantly clear he
was going to be participating
prominently in the Democratic primary
debates only then did corporate media
actually start talking about Bernie
Sanders and mostly even on so-called a
balanced news and I'm not alluding to
Fox News specifically but news programs
versus opinion programs it was still not
in a very serious manner for a very very
long time so I think all of that
together along with the sort of
deliberate confusion between democratic
socialism which is again regulated
capitalism and quote socialism I think
all of that together drastically hurt
bernie sanders you briefly alluded to on
a version that some people may have to
the word socialism where does that come
from is that from people's experience or
their thoughts on the Cold War I think
that although if you ask most people
whether their skepticism of socialism is
because of the Cold War I think most
people would say no however I think it
undeniable that the environment that was
created by the Cold War has had the
leftover impact of sort of pervading
society in a way that lots of people
here socialism and they think communism
and don't necessarily understand the
difference I think that that's that's
sort of number one so the sort of
environment that was created the
predisposition that was created by the
Cold War is a factor and it's also a
misunderstanding of a lot of the
modern-day realities of the United
States where we have socialism so called
socialism for a lot of aspects of
American society and it's a lot of those
aspects work pretty well and again what
that really gets us to is we're talking
about democratic socialism when we talk
about using tax money to fund health
care for everybody or using tax money to
make it so that more people can afford
to go to college etc you still have
private business you still have the
ability to have successful businesses
that will lead to the personal
enrichment of individuals what we're
saying though is that society benefits
from sharing in the cost of certain
services and and aspects of society that
will actually be a rising tide that
lifts all boats and I think that it's a
combination of just general antipathy to
socialism because of the history of the
u.s. combined with just a
misunderstanding of what democratic
socialism sort of actually is just going
back to bunny cylinders very quickly do
you think he would have beaten Donald
Trump if he was the Democratic nominee
there's a really good case to be made
that he would have and it's very very
difficult to weigh something like that
because on the one hand we had Hillary
Clinton a candidate with significant
baggage whether or not you believe that
Benghazi and the emails were actually
scandals and Benghazi absolutely not the
email thing you know the Bush
administration lost
2 million emails Colin Powell Secretary
of State used a private email server we
found out that up until a few days ago
here in the US Steve Bannon and
Kellyanne Conway and others involved
with the Trump administration were also
maintaining private emails through the
Republican National Committee it was
drastically overblown but undeniably it
had an effect so if you say hey if you
had a candidate without that like Bernie
Sanders were only talking about 77,000
votes in three states that had to go the
other way that would have flipped the
election at the same time if Donald
Trump had been running against bernie
sanders he would have campaigned
differently and and it's very hard to
measure what that would have been like I
think someone who says that the
Democrats would have had as good a shot
against Trump with Bernie Sanders and
Hillary Clinton are probably right
finally you talked about left wingers in
the US needing to improve the message
they present to people and that PR
campaign do you think that that sort of
change is achievable from within the
Democratic Party it really depends on
whether there's a sort of recognition of
what went wrong and the ways in which
some strategic elements of the
Democratic Party don't work and to sort
of go back to the identity politics
example you can be in the way that that
I am incredibly cognizant and concerned
about the ways in which different
minority groups are disproportionately
hurt by the status quo of American
politics and our economic system etc and
recognize that the sort of concentrated
focus or attempt to appeal to people
based on identity is not a winning
strategy right that's that's sort of
where where I am once you recognize that
you have to sort of make a decision
about the direction that you want to go
in so is it possible that the Democratic
Party makes these decisions and
and goes in a direction of having an
economic message that encompasses the
concerns of these minority identity
groups absurd several groups of which I
am a member right I mean I'm an
immigrant from South America to the
United States I'm a minority in that i'm
also a jewish a religious minority
although I consider myself more sort of
culturally Jewish I'm not a religious
person in any way so I understand those
concerns but I also recognize that it
may be difficult for me to bring in
others into my way of thinking if I only
focus on my identity as a Jewish person
or as a South American immigrant who
learned english as a second language or
whatever i can imagine though making
really good partnerships with people of
different identities by saying hey I'm
really concerned about the economic
situation the kleptocracy that we have
etc etc and that still if dealt with is
going to improve the situation for
immigrants from South America religious
minorities whatever the case may be so
taking my example i think the democratic
party could also look at that and say
here's how we have to craft the message
i don't know how emma cratic party like
the Republican Party these are huge huge
institutions how quickly can they really
move right we're already only 10 months
away from the beginning of the 2018
midterm election cycle we're a third of
our senators and all of members of the
House of Representatives will be up for
re-election how quickly can such a
strategy be put together I don't know I
hope pretty quickly there are all people
who generally speaking consider a left
wing goes to be overbearing or to pc is
there something to that and does that
need to be fixed well I so the pc sing
political correctness is a sort of
double edged sword I have been critical
of what I described is over over over
over bearing difficult word to say today
political correctness to the extent that
it exists and I've given some examples
of that however by and large critics
political correctness are just upset
that there's some something they can't
say anymore that they would like to be
saying and this is why one of the first
questions I'll ask someone who says hey
you know what and in fact I had callers
to my shows that I voted for Trump
because he's against political
correctness and my question is what is
there that you would like to be able to
say or do that you feel you can't
because of the supposed overbearing
political correctness that exists and
very quickly you will get to one of to
respond to that question one though
there will be a realization of a good
point actually I there's really nothing
that I wish I could say that I feel I
can't because of overbearing political
correctness I guess it's not an issue or
two you will get to some losses hey you
know what I'd really like to be
referring to Jews Hispanics black gay
people with x word and I feel like I
can't so so I think that that's a really
good question as a starting point
anybody who sees so-called overbearing
political correctness as a problem I've
been a critic of the sort of safe space
mentality that's taking place in some
aspects of American culture some
universities etc but i also am careful
not to overblow the extent to which
that's a problem and again i think that
it's a problem in the sense that
identity politics is a problem within
the American left it's a problem that
exists in some areas it's not the
problem and I think it's important to
maintain some sense of balance in terms
of what we want to focus on but it's
been a problem for you to some degree
hasn't it because recently I think
yesterday even there were people from
the political last big commentators who
criticized you and who some may consider
to have been overbearing in that
criticism for simply interviewing and
being critical of a Richard Spencer
isn't that an example of the of
something people should be white fully
concerned about I don't know that that's
an example of political correctness I
mean the critiques of my interview with
this all right self-described white
nationalist leader Richards
the critiques were not coming from what
I would consider a political correctness
perspective they were this is not
someone who deserves to be given any
airtime and it's just sort of a
fundamental difference of philosophy I
mean I've interviewed I don't know if
it's 30 40 or 50 so-called extremists of
different kinds and my perspective is
I'm not saying hey take an hour of my
show and just parrot your propaganda in
a context that suggests i support you or
agree with you the context is I am a
progressive I am completely and clearly
against many of the ideas of the people
that I interview and the context will be
how did someone get to believe what it
is that they believe let's explore how
that is now there are people and this is
a legitimate debate even in what I
consider to be sensible communities
should individuals with deplorable
beliefs be no platform or should their
beliefs be heard and understood so that
they can better be fought against and we
can be aware of them I obviously take
the latter approach and it's not
illegitimate to take the first approach
I think there are some pragmatic issues
with number one where do you draw the
line right so if it's not allowable to
interview a white nationalist what about
somebody who's anti-gay I find anti-gay
believes to be completely deplorable but
for a long time and it still is but
obviously we've had changing legislation
here in the US it was an issue that was
on the forefront and I believed it to be
important to figure out where where does
homophobia come from where do what are
these beliefs rooted it and I think you
really get into a problem of well if I
find someone who has ninety percent
beliefs I agree within ten percent
beliefs that I find deplorable are they
also not supposed to be interviewed I
just think it's a dangerous path to go
down okay David thank you my pleasure so
I read that and tremble because that's a
description of what a human being is
right you know you think it was the not
to do you think it was pisonia that's
rubbish it with you if you don't
understand that then you're weak
an uninformed and dangerous
you